I was doing about this room for the past
eleven and a half months I'm gonna make
sure that nothing like this ever happens
again that's just one of several tearful
moments in the season seven trailer for
The Real Housewives of New Jersey at the
time Teresa Giudice is husband Joe was
preparing to serve a prison sentence of
his own and Bravo cameras captured the
emotional moments he needs to go so that
he could just like get it going we will
get through it
Traci you're so sure after that you
can't change what it is the only thing
we got to do is just get through it
you know that could you make daddy come
home quick because I really love her so
much
also coming up this season will meet two
new housewives Delores and siggy and of
course there's plenty more signature
Jersey drama
you sent your porno Jean those cars
sound like that you're getting in her
face like that criminal The Real
Housewives of New Jersey season 7
premieres Sunday July 10th on Bravo
cheers dad
you